amber heard sister whitney enriquez is
speaking out after the actress's loss in
johnny depp's defamation lawsuit
this comes as e.t learns new details
about johnny and amber and how they're
navigating life in the trial's aftermath
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
first whitney shares a public message of
support for amber on instagram alongside
this image with the hashtag i stand with
amber heard whitney writes in part we
knew that this was going to be an uphill
battle and that the cards were stacked
against us you'll recall last month
whitney testified on her sister's behalf
that's when johnny runs up the stairs
and
my again i'm facing amber
he comes up behind me
strikes me in the back on the stand she
described alleged acts of abuse from
johnny against her and amber johnny had
already grabbed amber by the hair with
one hand and was whacking her repeatedly
in the face with the other weeks later
whitney says she has no regrets adding
in her message i am so honored to
testify for you and i would do it a
million times over because i know what i
saw and because truth is forever on your
side amber has worked so hard to
overcome
everything that she went through in the
duration of their relationship
amber plans to appeal the court's
decision and e.t is learning the actress
feels very alone a source tells us amber
is not in a good place and is worried in
general and financially speaking she is
sad that people she hoped would support
her didn't in the short term the source
adds amber's plan right now is to focus
on being a mom she's going to try not to
do anything public for a while and is
hopeful that after some time passes she
can slowly build her career back
how is she today what is her next move
she's right well her next move is appeal
there was another heartbroken she is
heartbroken that's amber's attorney
elaine bredhoft sharing her own reaction
on cbs mornings one of the first things
that she said when she came back from
the verdict when we went into the
conference room was i am so sorry to all
these women elaine says the jury's
verdict sends a message to all domestic
abuse victims
basically what this said you know amber
had an enormous amount of evidence
although a lot of it was suppressed in
this case as opposed to the uk but look
at all the women who have no evidence
all these women who suffer from domestic
violence domestic abuse
they don't have evidence and basically
what this jury said is unless you pull
out your cell phone and you tape record
your spouse beating you you're out of
luck
meanwhile johnny depp is in a
celebratory mood
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning that the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence another
source tells e.t johnny is feeling
really good and positive after the
verdict he's looking forward to the
future both personally and
professionally and feels like he got his
career back